Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for waking up.
For waiting up?
For waking up!
Or staying up late?
Maybe waiting up late.
And joining us for our 107th episode today, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
It's the middle of the week, Ruffians.
How are you feeling?
Are you ready to go?
Maybe not yet.
Ruffians!
I think I see some new faces out there!
So maybe that means today is your first FUWAMOCO Morning!
Maybe it is!
Let me explain!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
You missed something.
Was I thinking about how hot it was in here and where the air conditioning controller was?
I made a mistake.
No right paw!
Right!
No hashtag!
Hashtag hot!
My mind is in a different place.
It's hot and sweaty, hot!
Ruffians!
Hi!
You didn't even notice!
Hot!
Where were we?
Our aim?
What's our aim?
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw and get some air conditioning going on.
Get some air conditioning.
Help you start off your day on the right paw and have air conditioning on your left paw.
Yeah.
I got it.
I got it on the left paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Definitely not chilly enough.
Ruffians, I think it's gonna get a little cooler here.
So I hope that you're all cool and comfy now.
Or if you're chilly, that you're warm and toasty.
And that your day starts off on the right paw.
Well, this next bit of news.
I'm not sure if it's gonna make you feel hot or cold.
Does that make me feel...temporate?
Temporate?
Well... Let us know how you feel, okay?
Does it make you feel hot or cold, Ruffians?
There's been...another Pero Sighting.
Let's see where he is.
De-den!
Peron, I need an X-Bow!
He wasn't invited!
Ruffian, did you call the call in security?
Get him hauled away!
That's the right answer!
So nasty!
I guess he just thought he could blend into the crowd, huh?
But no!
No.
We all know that nasty roundness, huh?
Yeah.
Ugh, so round.
Wow.
Yeah, but we're glad to know that you didn't let him ruin our performance!
Yes!
Thank you for BAU BAU-ing and having a lot of fun with us!
BAU BAU!
Do you feel nasty now, Ruffians?
Right, he was there.
Do you feel a bit- Ugh!
You just thought he could blend in, huh?
Yeah.
Security will be fast!
They'll get him!
Yeah.
You feel happy.
That's not cool, girls.
I feel nasty but also hot.
Nasty and hot.
Hopefully the air conditioning reaches you soon.
Nasty and cute.
I think you're confused.
You understand what cute means?
Right!
No.
BAU BAU!
Well, speaking of hot right now, it's summertime and that's why it's so hot.
And speaking of summertime fun, well there are some big updates to the hololive City event that's gonna be happening all across Japan this summer!
You know, this summer, theme parks across Japan will be paying up with hololive to put on some more
Summer fun.
Yeah, some summer fun.
Summer, summer fun.
Summer, summer fun!
And FUWAMOCO!
What part of the two are gonna be together with some wonderful senpai?
Representing Tokyo Dome City attractions.
And some new details about the collab was just released!
Wow, you saw it!
You saw it!
Well, in case you didn't see it.
Yeah, well, you know, first,
Lots of merch, you know, like a crim look style, and t-shirts, and clear files.
Lots of fun stuff!
But FUWAMOCO, we're actually, we're also in charge of the ride, the hoppin' droppin'!
Hoppin' droppin'!
Bikini!
So colorful, like a ride!
Ride on droppin'!
Not just that, Ruffians, but a unique voice message from us will play, as well as hololive music during the ride, too!
It looks super cute and really fun!
A big responsibility.
Please make sure you write it.
Enjoy Tokyo Dome City with us!
I know.
I saw some Ruffians saying that.
They'll be brave.
They'll get on the ride without being embarrassed.
Yeah.
Why would you be embarrassed?
Yeah, but you know that's the spirit, right?
You gotta BAU BAU that embarrassment away.
Not kiddie rides!
No, no.
Okay, Ruffie!
Not baby rides!
Come here, I'm gonna BAU BAU all the way on this ride with you.
Ruffian's hardcore.
Yeah, look.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
No, this is the Hoppin' Droppin'.
Hoppin' Droppin'.
And this is FUWAMOCO's territory.
Yeah.
Okay.
But, you know, after you go on the Hoppin' Droppin', like BAU BAU BAU, that was so much fun.
Hoppin' Droppin', Hoppin' Hoppin'.
You might be in the mood for some extra yummy club treats.
Wow!
And you know, when you think about sweets and FUWAMOCO, what comes to mind, Ruffians?
Or... Or... Maybe... Some... Donuts!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
We got some super cute BAU BAU donuts that are FUWAMOCO kind!
It's a bit hard to see, but they even have, you know, a headband.
Yeah, and then we also have a very fluffy and fuzzy shaved ice too!
There's complete sugar stars on top as well!
So cute!
I love FUWAMOCO colors!
Right?
It looks so good, right?
I want to eat it!
Please eat it!
You know, maybe there'll be some Ruffians that are planning a trip to Japan too.
Maybe you'll be visiting the Tokyo area.
If that's the case, you'll definitely definitely want to go and check out Tokyo Dome City attractions and go on all the rides and see everything you have to see there.
Please do, okay?
The kids will absolutely love these.
Everyone will love them!
Especially FUWAMOCO.
I hope you can visit!
You can check out the homepage for more information about the event.
Yeah, there's lots of fun stuff, so please check it out, okay?
BAU BAU!
And another super surprising and happy update, Ruffians!
We, FUWAMOCO, our birthday was early in the year, but the birthday merch, our first ever birthday merch, it has started shipping!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for reading excitedly, Ruffians!
We're so happy!
You know, Ruffian plushies, the signatures, the shirts, they're starting to reach your paws!
You know, we were just talking about it the other day, like, I hope they get to you soon, Ruffians!
And now look!
We put so much love into each one, so we hope that if you are lucky,
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Maybe we'll decide to put your FUWAMOCO love keychains in your bag.
Maybe... Where's Pero's merch?
Hi.
Ruffians, you understand this is our birthday merch, not Pero's birthday merch.
Pero doesn't even know when was Pero born.
Nobody cares.
Yeah.
And Ruffians, you know, our first birthday merch has finally arrived.
Maybe, you know, maybe that FUWAMOCO shine, maybe a bloom?
A blossom?
A blossom has bloomed.
What?
It's not spring anymore!
It's spring for the FUWAMOCO shrine maiden!
So you know, if you've been working on one, maybe it might start rapidly expanding soon!
Please let us know how the FUWAMOCO Shine is going, Ruffians!
How much you enjoy everything!
It doesn't all ship out, so you might get your notice soon, okay?
Soon, yeah.
You might not have gotten it yet.
But very soon, FUWAMOCO friends are getting them now.
So, soon.
BAU BAU!
We're excited!
And well, also you know, a big part of the summer of Advent.
Recently, we shared the news with you that
FUWAMOCO, the pervert!
FUWAMOCO, the advent!
We'll be partnering together with FUWAMOCO to release some apparel!
And it just went on sale recently, Ruffians!
We're able to get your paws on some!
We saw some Ruffians already out on the beltway, then reached you!
Yeah, thank you!
You got yours!
Got the stuff!
Yeah, you got your clothes!
We've been so happy and proud seeing you wear them!
Seeing you proudly wear them!
Not just wear them, you know.
Here's a shirt on my body.
No, it's a... This is FUWAMOCO's shirt!
You're making them all so fashionable!
Nice coordinates.
It makes me so happy!
Yeah, you look so cool in a Ruffian!
But, you know, speaking of her... There are actually some hololive English skate decks that went on scale... scale?
Scale!
On sale!
The skate decks went on sale!
And!
Ah, ah, FUWAMOCO.
We also had a skate deck too!
Yeah!
I know.
And I guess we are a bit surprised.
Yeah.
Because it seems like a lot of Ruffians really like to skate around in their hobby.
Because they all sold out super fast!
Ruffians!
We are so surprised!
You all skateboard!
I thought Ruffians, you know, like to BAU BAU.
I guess they like to do flips too.
We're able to get one Ruffians!
Are you still glad that we don't escape?
You could, you could.
Come FUWAMOCO Mine!
No.
We can't ride a bike.
You got it!
You can do flips!
Well that means Ruffians, you gotta do some flips at the same time then!
Or, you know, maybe if you don't skate yet, you could decorate your room with it too!
Well, we hope that maybe this will inspire you to not
Learn some cool tricks.
Maybe you can take some photos and use the hashtag FWMCMORNING to let us know you've been skating too!
Imagine a video of a Ruffian being like BAU BAU BAU!
We know a lot of Ruffians are also a little bit sad that they weren't able to get their paws on them before they sold out.
But we hope that there's a restock sometime soon in the future, Ruffians.
So don't give hope up yet, okay?
Don't give up hope yet.
BAU BAU!
Sighting Ruffians!
I wanna see your flips, okay?
Let's see your flips!
But also don't get hurt, okay?
No getting hurt.
We'll protect your smile, but we can't protect your bones.
BAU BAU!
Helmet days!
Absolutely.
Knee pads.
Elbow pads.
And you know what?
Maybe you can find a helmet that has ears.
Is that safe?
Safety first, safety first.
BAU BAU!
On the topic of safety.
FUWAMOCO!
We went to the doctor!
The day we visited the doctor.
And you know, it's been really busy and we've been running around like crazy.
On top of things, you know,
Our barkers, they've been barking like they've never barked before over the last few months.
So, you know, today was an important day to go visit the doctor and see how they are doing.
We're a little worried, but the doctor said that our barkers look beautiful and sent us quickly on our way with new photos to give to Shiori.
Yeah, Moco-chan was like, um, there's somebody who wants a photo, so can you make sure you give me a photo?
Doctor,
Yeah.
Will I get another photo as a souvenir today?
Because I have a friend that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
I think this time, I'm pretty sure last time it wasn't in color.
I think it was.
I don't know, I think the doctor might have printed in color just for her.
I don't know now, it's a little bit... Wow.
But, you know, we were really happy that everything was all good!
Yes!
You know, the only advice we got was to drink even more water.
For our barkers.
Even though we already drink a lot of water.
Yeah.
Every day.
More than two liters.
So make sure you drink water till okay, Ruffians!
We'll do whatever is best for our health.
BAU BAU!
Is it important to drink water?
Okay.
Not coffee.
Not soda.
No.
Water.
Okay.
Good for you.
Water!
Not coffee!
Not watermelon!
No.
No watermelon is good, but not watermelon!
Water.
H2O.
Okay.
How about tea?
The doctor said not tea!
He said water.
Only one cup of tea, okay?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Oops, you're drinking coffee right now.
That's okay.
You can have a little coffee right now.
You know, it is the morning.
But make sure after that it's always water, okay?
BAU BAU!
Listen to the doctor, okay?
Actually, there's something that's been a little bit on my mind for the past few days.
Maybe some Ruffians already heard, but something really happy happened to us!
You know, the other day, we were in our most intense and long dance practice yet.
And FUWAMOCO, we were doing our absolute best.
We were very sweaty puppies.
And we were just working like dogs.
And we were absolutely exhausted.
A bit frustrated.
Yeah.
While we were just taking a moment to gather our breath, suddenly I got a big hug from behind!
At first, you know, I was like, oh, no way!
But it turned out it was Marine-senchou-senpai!
She came to give us a big hug!
A big hug.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I'll never, ever, ever forget it.
I was so, so, so, so surprised and so happy.
It just makes me so happy.
Incredibly happy when I think about it.
I know we are both- No tummy touching!
No, just a hug.
Just a soft and warm hug.
We are both really, really tired.
We're worried about if we're doing well.
So, it really meant so much to us at that moment.
Thank you for the wonderfully warm and soft hugs, my FUWAMOCO!
I don't think we'll ever ever forget them, FUWAMOCO-chan.
I can still feel it.
Did you feel the moment?
Did you capture the moment?
I captured the moment!
I can feel Marine-senchou-senpai on my back!
She captured the moment!
I captured it!
BAU BAU!
But it was sad news.
It seems like Senchou-senpai is pretty sick right now.
So let's all wish her a speedy recovery, okay?
BAU BAU!
Get better soon!
Ruffians!
Make sure that you stay healthy too, okay?
Wash those paws!
Get lots of sleep.
Make sure you get vitamins too, okay?
But maybe, you know, Ruffians, maybe there's a vitamin that you can't get from, you know, some good spinach.
Natto.
Maybe a vitamin that only Moco-chan... A vitamin Moco-chan can give.
What type of vitamin is that?
I think it's a... Mococo Pup Talk?
No.
Is that a vitamin?
Ruffians, is that a vitamin?
Vitamin MCC.
FWMC.
Hi!
Yeah!
BAU Moco-chan!
Hi!
We want the vitamin!
Give us the vitamin!
Ruffians!
It's that day of the week again!
It's time for a famous Mococo Pup Talk!
Famous?
Famous.
Are you gonna hear it?
Sing for me, Mococo!
I... I have been sleeping, Ruffians.
A bit tired.
I... My eyes feeling so heavy.
That they could be rocks.
It's okay!
It's okay, Ruffians!
You can take a bit of a break.
It's important to have a bit of rest and some fun time every now and then to re-energize yourself, you know?
Even if it's something just like going to get your favorite yummy treat or hanging out with a friend or a family member for a bit.
You know, it can really make a change in your energy levels, right?
If you're feeling super sleepy and you just can't shake that feeling, it's okay to take a nice rest, okay?
You're always doing your best, but you need to sleep so then you can continue to go go go too, okay?
And good night to those who want to sleep.
And good morning to those who are ready to go, okay?
You can do it!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Do your best, Ruffians!
Well, maybe let's take a look at today's Doggie of the Day, shall we?
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Luna!
Luna!
BAU BAU!
Look at the silly pinkie pie!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
She loves giving kisses.
That's what I mean.
She's just a little puppy still.
Right.
Just a cute nibble.
Yeah.
That's right!
A cute nibble.
Yeah.
But yeah, she loves giving kisses.
I'm sure getting kisses too.
But also very much loves belly rubs.
She loves to go on walks too.
Yeah!
Yeah.
I just wanna give her a big head pat!
But I wanna touch the cheeks.
The cheeks?
Yeah.
How do you think Luna BAU BAUs?
BAU BAU!
Like that.
So it sounds a little bit like a Pokemon.
No.
No, that's how Luna BAU BAU is.
Luna's the Doggie of the Day!
Luna is Luna!
Well, you know, Luna is a sweetheart to everyone.
And she's always super friendly, wanting to get to know everybody.
But, but, but... If you're Raccoon, she hasn't forgotten about the time that you stole her food.
She doesn't forget easily.
Yeah, so... You might get BAU BAU'd away a little bit.
But I'm sure you know, as long as you bring back some food, maybe things will be better.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Let's see what kind of solo adventures you've been having lately.
Where have you been going for a walk recently?
Today's walk is... De-den!
It's us!
Such a beautiful view!
Did we go up the mountain together with you?
We're there together with you!
FUWAMOCO wanna hike and look!
We're ready for some adventures in our expo outfit there.
Look at our shirt!
Proper hiking outfit.
Thank you for, you know, taking us along with you and bringing the pon-de-ring offsprings for us!
Biboo.
That's not a boy!
But we love going on adventures!
Thank you!
Which do FUWAMOCO prefer?
Team Beach or Team Mountain?
It's Mountain!
Mountain.
Beach.
I'm feeling so hot.
Mountain.
If you want a bathing suit up the mountain.
No.
BAU BAU!
Today we have our Question of the Day!
What kind of question did we receive this time?
De-den!
Good day FUWAMOCO!
Good day!
Q. How do you communicate to cats?
Do you go up
Cat, cat!
Come here, come here!
Just like that, Ruffians.
You don't do that!
It works well.
It's not kissy, it's... That's how you call the cat to you.
You do the same, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
No, Ruffians!
Just like that.
Just like that, and it works.
It works!
It works.
Do you believe us, Moffins?
If you were a cat, what would it be?
Teach us again!
What?
I can't remember.
I need a cat here.
Yeah.
It works.
Oh yeah.
Only sometimes it doesn't work.
But maybe that's because they didn't hear us, huh?
Or maybe because we're chasing them.
Maybe.
That's how we communicate to cats.
Kisses.
Sniffs.
BAU BAU!
Eating isn't part of the communication right?
FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that we make together, so it means so much to us that you're here bright and early here with us, and that you also share, you know, your Doggie of the Day, your Mocs, questions, and your Pero Sightings.
And don't forget we also have the hashtag FWMC scoop for any interesting new hololive scoops that might have popped up that you're like, oh!
FUWAMOCO need to hear about this!
Thank you so much Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream we have...
De-den!
Donkey Kong Country 2!
We're continuing our adventure.
Right now we're on such a cool level.
It's very different from anything in Donkey Kong Country so far.
But I can't help but think... Miyuki.
Don't you know about Miyuki from Donkey Kong Country 2?
There's a heroine that's suffering.
She's in the hospital.
Maybe she doesn't have much longer.
We have to see how Miyuki does.
As we get to the level and gather all the bananas and continue on our adventure in Donkey Kong Country 2.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a peek at our schedule.
Our schedule here at the Donkey Kong Country 2.
It's a little bit early at 4 am PT.
Moco-chan and I are going to be chained together.
Chained together!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
Well, we're gonna do our best!
Please join us, Ruffians!
But maybe if you know it's a little bit early, maybe if you're like, oh, that's when I get my, like, you know, my, my sleep.
Then, get your sleep.
Sleep is important, okay?
And the archive will be there later, and then, you know, later, you know, if you're like, I wanna see FUWAMOCO live, too!
Well, we're gonna be having an epic live!
Chatting all about Japan over on Nerissa's channel!
But it's just us and Nerissa.
There's been a little bit of changes.
It's just gonna be us and Nerissa.
When we ask Nerissa, Nerissa, maybe we should change things.
You know we could do something else.
Nerissa's like, no.
I just wanna chat about how much I love you, FUWAMOCO.
Right?
Is that how much she said?
How did she word it?
She said, ah... Oh.
How much we love each other.
She's thinking cause she's a bird.
BAU BAU!
And then also, we're gonna be doing a Rock n' Rawr Party, the first one in a very long time!
And then FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be in Australia for Smash!
We're gonna be seeing a bunch of Australian Ruffians, and then BAU BAU-ing it out all together!
And then on Sunday!
Time to verse Advent.
Verse Justice!
Verse Justice Advent!
We'll be versing justice in Party Animals.
You know, we're demon dogs.
I don't know if we're Party Animals, but we're demon dogs.
Somewhere gonna be justice!
BAU BAU!
Take care, Ruffians!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO to share with us in the comments.
It's BAU BAU backflip!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra-special Ruffians!
Yuki!
BAU BAU!
Imcomild!
GTLizmo!
BAU BAU!
Talking BB!
Terrified!
BAU BAU!
Ibukuro.
Blue Lava Lamp.
BAU BAU!
Slime.
Steve Jang.
BAU BAU!
Ellipsis.
Book it please!
BAU BAU!
Green tea on purple purple book!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!